you're uh
very much in tune with the with with
movies acting etc
give me your
three movies if you're on an island you
can only take three movies with you what
are what are the flicks we're taking man
um
all right
so we gonna go
roots
okay no roots of course no i'm talking
about yes there's like so many of them
oh that's a crazy choice crazy choice to
take on an island
for sure watching just be mad all day
yeah it's roots
um i'm down with that because if i'm on
the island i'd rather be mad
right yeah because it'll motivate you to
get off the island okay fair enough yeah
so we go roots
you know t.i was in the roots they
upgraded the movie the movie came out of
like 1960. you know t.i was in when it
came out in like 2011 or something right
about the same he was a slave
it's kind of crazy but he was talking
like yeah of today
you gotta see it you gotta see it
it was amazing so he was hitting like
what the ill the ill t.i is just killing
that [ __ ] but
on slave clothes
and i would try to bring that version
too because tia is crazy i didn't even
know there was this version that's like
you know that did you know there's a
belly too yeah with the game terrible
movie i watch horrible movies and great
movies all the time
belly belly posters up above you it's
the best worst movie ever
it's such a great movie i don't know if
i agree with that it's so many epic
movie epic parts in that movie that's
classic in our culture that no but
storyline no no i agree story like as a
kid is like my favorite [ __ ] movie
but i grow up and i'm like every time i
re-watch belly i'm like god damn this
storyline was terrible
boy listen that [ __ ]
the dude in nebraska eating a banana
that's what i feel did that
that's what popped off dmx career is
acting right was this before no no no
dmx
was already him he was already him okay
he already had two number one albums i
didn't say i'm talking about as far as
acting though was he acting before this
was this one as his first it might have
rose that got him into romeo almost died
exit wounds
was this happened this was first
yeah that's what i meant i think that
what it didn't do was kick off nasa's
acting career because he was god awful
in a sincere hey
it's like yo
you just gotta get out of here he was
talking to the little nick on the beach
oh my god
we just gotta make it
i wanna go to africa
my god
t.i was or naz was uh it was not the uh
crazy he had no rules after that
none none that we know about yeah he was
in a movie called ticker
i swear this is a straight to dvd like
movie where he was in the movie for like
two minutes
and then they kill him but you know back
in the day they used to put rappers in
movies so they could put them on the
artwork so people would rent it and buy
it and i was the one who would run in
and buy it and uh he was he was in it
for two minutes
wasn't diddy and monster ball for two
minutes yeah
he was in prison
by the way
raisin in the sun wasn't listening
made made with v with uh vince vaughn
wow but monsters ball
all-time one of the all-time best nude
scenes
yeah
see i got a problem with the white guy
part of it
i got a black problem with some
yeah i get it but i listen i guess
billy bob was handling it billy coat the
coat the head coach with friday night
lights yeah my sling blade billy bob
thornton oh [ __ ] sleep well yeah yeah
hey paul hey paul yeah yeah yeah that
was him that was crap bro i just had a
problem with that
and best yeah yeah i can't i can't i was
so into halle berry as a kid really bob
not sick so that was the second movie
not a sexy man second movie all time
halle berry's breasts were exposed the
first one was swordfish with hugh
jackman and john travolta yes
i had it on vhs and i broke the tape
because i'd pause it on her tits so much
that is savage so you got a little
scratch on it oh yeah it was fun
i was like am i supposed to drink off
this anymore um all right you got two
more movies and then you get the [ __ ]
out of here before we both get canceled
we have a good time yeah we're having
fun
two more movies you got roots both
versions the ti version yeah so that's
all one that's always roots yes boom um
imma go i'ma go
avengers the end in game [ __ ]
okay yeah
wait end game is the part one of the
when they when thanos when they done
when they get cooked right now when they
come back
oh no i thought it's all the same kind
of right don't they
i'll be confused so one of them [ __ ]
one of the movies okay and i'ma go
apocalypto apocalypto yeah wow there's a
lot of variety there
apocalypto doesn't really have any like
isn't it like in like a
they're like in the jungle and they're
yeah there's like male gets to mayan
yep
mel gibson had he not been such a piece
of [ __ ] one of the best directors
amazing he actually did that jesus film
too as well trust me i'm a [ __ ] i'm
in high school on a date watching the
[ __ ] what's that [ __ ] called the
jesus [ __ ] it's crazy what was it called
passion of the christ christ and i'm an
atheist i don't give a [ __ ] about jesus
but he made me give a [ __ ]
don't say that to me he made me care man
that was crazy right there
i care i'm a god for your man kev
i respect your right to be a god-fearing
man
i fear
uh like my kid's dying or something you
know i have children i fear them getting
sick i understand i fear aliens in the
ocean
caleb
there hey there's you know have you ever
done psychedelics
you know you didn't have [ __ ]
psychedelics yeah you believe you're
you're getting something there's some
inclination how about this i think more
recently since i've been a little bit
more awakened on the uh
psychedelic tip
maybe i'm not an atheist but i tell you
what i just don't believe in something
i'll tell you this i don't believe in
any man-made religion
i think it's all a way to
control populations control poor people
and it's big business yeah and it's some
of the most corrupt hypocrisy of all
time you know what i'm saying so uh yeah
i guess that's my stance how would you
i'm more of a i don't know
yeah but i've lived in a haunted house
so if i've lived in a haunted house then
that means that there's some other [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] do you do what do you mean
he lived in a haunted house lived i
lived in a house that was on how you
know it was on it bro we'd [ __ ] wake
up in the middle of the night and all
the pots and pans would be out and all
the doors would be open crazy thing i uh
bought a house and renovated renting
they had a funeral or a wake okay you
know what i'm saying they showed it
and i was always thinking about stuff
like that so you kind of freaked me out
when you said it no for sure it was uh
our house was over uh a native american
graveyard
so it's pretty [ __ ] wild the house
that uh during this era though my dad
was smoking crack so i could have just
put him in the middle of the night open
up [ __ ]
who knows i don't know reagan got you
too huh
[Laughter]
it was never noticeable you know like he
was like very functional you know what i
mean and i think he just had his little
bouts with it but me and my me and my
best friend
like the army or anything no no no no no
no no no no no um but me and my best
friend ramses uh we were aziz like yes
of egypt it's my best friend in the
world his name is
yes ramsay's rudy king taylor the son do
you like prince of egypt yeah good
cartoon okay keep going here so uh
we're like thick in masterpiece ghetto
dope era of like my childhood i had a no
limit chain
i shoplifted a no limit clothing jersey
from mr rags you know
and i'm going through my dad's drawer
next to his bed i forget what me and
ramsay are you friendly i'm from phoenix
phoenix [ __ ] hot place all right
the crack makes it and we found crack
and and my boy rams just pulled it out
and he was like yo this is the ghetto d
[ __ ]
i said damn my dad he's like smoking
crack what the [ __ ] [ __ ] but but but
outside of that and then my mom later on
telling me yeah your dad smoke cracker
every once in a while for a little bit
but i never noticed it as a kid it
wasn't like he was like my dad was like
a really hard working dude he worked
like non-stop so he was probably the
most functional crackhead of all time
one of them at least
lots of functional uh drug drug users
yeah anyway listen man